planen getan was kaputt gehören sowas
dinge passieren iphone in der mikrowelle
und es geht kaputt und das sieht richtig
heftig aus hat dass mal ein häppchen
weniges geschaut ja ich nehme nichts
raus wirft ihr holz weg es reicht nicht
die holz
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der handicaps weniger
von krankhafter und zwar lauter ist man
darf nur die spawn kisten öffnen keine
anderen und es geht los
keine waffe kann auch europa habe ich
glück gehabt habe ich glück gehabt alter
junge hat in der ersten kisten uhr food
da macht die zweite küste auf
fünfeinhalb rüstungsteile heute also was
ist was nicht fünfter abrisses teile
aber so ein halbes rüstungsteile aber
auf jeden fall beide seiten die einzige
möglichkeit für mac wird man zu bekommen
ist dass gegner zu töten so und da hat
mich erst mal raus jetzt drauf oder
musst du sagen ich bin auf jeden fall
hat maxi diese technisch ausgeladen zwar
gestern kam die konnten gestern bekannt
ich habe einen charmanten als handicap
für dich und man sagt ja ich so ein paar
wie lautet also wer die stars macht das
mal und jetzt sind wir hier und ich
finde die idee ist richtig gut aber was
geht da ab
im ernst es ist ein dreierteam glaube
schon
müssen wir anfangen die
auseinanderzunehmen kommen wir so an den
darin auseinander sagt okay zwei und
einen haben wir doch ruhig der andere
habe sturm nachdem hier deine kollegen
auseinander genommen habe dazu musste
sie qualvoll verrecken ich mir einfach
mehr drin
ich glaube von mir drin ich glaube wir
denn hier
surprise surprise mäßig okay das ist
sofort weg
der ist so aus versteht nicht wie können
wir heute im boden banken so also so
hardcore
manchmal hat man es echtes die leute
einfach im boden wagen aber einen selbst
ganz normal schlagen können aber gut die
andern wahrscheinlich auch nachteile
dass die irgendwie so im boden stecken
bleiben oder so auf jeden fall liegt ist
diese runde echt richtig gut bisher den
bundesrat darum unter wollen da hab ich
dich zack da fliegt das sehr gut wir
können da nichts essen was ist twitter
haben sehr sehr gut
denn nicht moment mal acht da hinten
sind hier muss wieder anders umgehen
egal wir haben die zeit wir haben die
zeiten mit umso kürbiskuchen durch die
gegend zweigen mit dem quiz koopmann
leute wie immer geht natürlich zu heute
bild gezeigt dem irgendwie so ein in
berching irish night live fotos auf dem
so eine tussi vor seinem typen knie zu
und aussieht als würde sie ihm einen ihr
wisst schon
und dann warum hat sie ein schwert in
der hand und die hat einfach irgendwie
ein behindertes plastikschwert keine
ahnung warum
auf jeden fall hatte schreibt eure
handicap sie immer in die kommentare
die sind sehr gern gesehen und echt ins
krassen schwanken die folge deutet weißt
schon viel länger aber es waren bisher
nur drei minuten das spiel in rapperswil
kompass ist und wer das wichtigste bei
der change ja du hast ganz geöffnet ja
gut ich darauf nicht ob ich da bin ich
raus holen dürfen wird ihn nur ma ja du
hast du hast recht du hast recht gut
dass ein schiedsrichter da ist aber
warteten erwartet machen deswegen strafe
sagte eine team was sie verkaufen muss
deinen stolz
ok alle starter selbst
jetzt ist das war es sind nicht
irgendwelche grenzen abstecken
matt kemp debatte hatte dem team as rom
reisen schwer was zur hölle los
ok heftig egal aber hat neue runde
wie gehen wir auf sg vier das ist glaube
ich das heftigste wenn man am anfang
ungefähr fast gar nichts kriegs start
und dann geht's los
321 mittlerweile kann man auf diese
routen fischer starten fahren geht das
noch nicht wussten eigentlich kann ich
das ja auch nicht aber ich gebe auf
diesem youtuber kommt aber verraten
kriege ich noch ärger mit onkel josé da
der mir nicht verraten mal war der
heimat schlug 32 antworten und wieder
nur so aus den anfangs kessen holen auch
glück gehabt glück gehabt meine fresse
die axt alter das war gut das war
richtig wohl die wahrscheinlichste davon
das war richtig gut aber ich hatte jetzt
gut daran wenn ich am anfang erstmal
raus hallte es vielleicht den da drüben
hat nur noch holz axt
online gelaufen zack zack zack zack sehr
gut das war wieder enorm wichtig walter
ich hab grad ebenso glück gehabt
ich habe nur eine ich habe nur einen
item aus der anfangs kiste bekommen und
zwar eine die axt alter das war richtig
lucky oder so eine riesen train control
für alle eishockey fans da draußen zum
allgemein sagt zack zack und den
nächsten und den nächsten an den
nächsten den wohn als auch noch dass wir
so ein kryptischer aber denk mir so
wasserschloss bayern hat da nicht
genannten bahn nehmen
fakten zu laufen aber es hat nicht so
raffiniert oder auch nicht hoffen der
wurde dann nicht hochkommen bisschen
hängen
aber ich freue mich was wir da machen
was wir da machen wir stehen hier oben
auf dem hausdach und welche
entscheidungen treffen die wir dein
schicksal besiegeln und und was macht ja
was macht ja was macht er
er macht das gut er bringt sich nicht
selbst um mich ehrlich gesagt sagt dass
er sich selbst umbringt jetzt aber das
ist nicht der fall wenn ihr darauf
unsere mutter ist man ein bisschen
seltsam aber ich weiß nicht ob er es
kennt also für alle die von euch die
muss ja gar nicht aufnehmen seien aber
zocken
er zeigt auch mutter einfach so mal ich
zocke und sie ja ok fünf minuten später
bitte mach mal das anders da wird jemand
sein iphone in die mikrowelle zum laden
getan und ist akteuren sowas dinge
passieren iphone in der mikrowelle und
es geht kaputt und das sieht richtig
heftig aus hat es mal rein
ja aber ich nehme nichts raus wäre
holzweg es reicht nicht die heute sagen
ich hab's immer geschafft
gefragt ist sein leben voll schlau und
so dinge passieren da drüben ist ein
gegner müssen gegner der mgm
wir holen uns zählen ich liebe das uns
durch die gegner durch zu sprengen diese
müssen und dabei seid mir selbst auch
noch zu verwirrung und ist aber alles
eine so aussehen zu lassen als hätte ich
irgendwie auch noch vor dem spiel heraus
fällt auf dass die weit ist guck mal
hier alter kiste öffnen
du musst raus muss ein bisschen darauf
achten nicht ich hab doch gesagt wie
check das ja aber zu spät da war ja
schon längst dran weiß ich was hab ich
mir rausgeholt schreiben die kommentare
was mir rausgeholt ich glaube ist war
diese hier aber okay den brustpanzer
muss um den brustpanzer muss ich auch
noch die strafe auspacken
aber dann darf ich dachte ja ein ziel
haben ich muss echt aufpassen die
schiedsmänner jedes mal selbst ins bein
wenn ich so etwas mache aber es beginnt
schon in 60 sekunden
und solange noch einmal die aufforderung
gesagt falls ich irgendwelche handicaps
einfach einfach ab in die kommentare
damit dann werdet ihr erwähnt wäre es
wohl oder ihr kriegt einen kurs weil man
will einmal aufnehmen und dann kommt
genau genau genau ja wahrscheinlich
wie hat er das gemacht
dieses doppel jetzt immer ja ja okay ich
schauen uns nach ein paar leute schreibt
eure handicaps in die kommentare
für die nächsten folgen seid kreativ
denke ich was aus und da will ich sagen
gucken jetzt auf fünf sekunden an